Transcriptor: Sara Mazzuferi
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En algunos temas muy importantes,
como la epidemia de COVID,
nos preocupa que las soluciones,
por ejemplo las vacunas,
tengan respaldo de pruebas científicas,
que se conozcan sus resultados y
entender cuál es la causa de la epidemia.
Sin embargo,
en otros temas como la inseguridad,
los gobiernos suelen ofrecer respuestas,
o las sociedades pedir políticas,
sin preguntarnos demasiado
cuáles son las causas de los problemas,
y la efectividad de las soluciones
que se implementan.
Así, en América Latina,
que tiene más de
140 000 homicidios al año,
con unas tasas más altas del mundo
y donde nos vamos a dormir
con miedo al delito,
los gobiernos gastan montañas de recursos
en políticas de prevención
sin que nos preguntemos en qué medida
eso sirve o no para disminuir el delito.
Como contrapartida,
el uso del conocimiento científico,
conocer las relaciones causa y efecto,
y saber el impacto de las políticas,
cuáles sirven y cuáles no,
es lo que ha hecho posible
saltos sustanciales en otros campos,
como el de la medicina,
el funcionamiento de las organizaciones,
la ingeniería o la economía.
En temas de seguridad,
sobre todo en el mundo desarrollado,
ha habido algunos avances,
pero con limitaciones.
Por ejemplo, un desarrollo exitoso
de análisis y prácticas de policiamento
en hotspots, puntos calientes,
el uso de herramientas predictivas
del delito o el uso de terapias cognitivas
en el programa
“Convertirse en un hombre” de Chicago
que permitían disminuir la participación
de jóvenes en delitos.
Mientras que en América Latina dichos
avances han sido mucho más lentos.
Realmente muy pocos.
Algunos ejemplos pueden ser:
un estudio bastante original
en su momento
sobre el impacto
del despliegue policial en el delito,
luego un ataque ocurrido en Buenos Aires,
un reciente diseño y evaluación
de intervenciones policiales
en hotspots en Uruguay que habría
permitido bajar los robos.
Un trabajo liderado
por la Universidad de Cambridge,
que salió este año y en el que participé,
sobre el impacto en el delito de las
medidas de restricción por COVID
en la que uno de los grandes obstáculos
que encontramos
fue que muchos gobiernos
no nos querían dar los datos.
Sin embargo,
si queremos reducir la inseguridad
y el riesgo de que nuestras familias
sean víctimas
de robos, ataques, homicidios,
debemos preguntarnos el porqué de ese
limitado uso de evidencias científicas
en la prevención del delito
y sobre cómo podemos remediarlo.
Bien, la relación
entre el mundo científico
y el de las políticas de seguridad
es compleja.
Un poco me hace acordar
a la definición que daba el psicoanalista
de Lacan sobre el amor
que decía que era dar algo que uno
no tiene a alguien que no lo quiere.
En ese sentido, distintos estudios
señalan los problemas y errores
que en ocasiones tienen
las investigaciones científicas,
las cuales no son infalibles.
Algunas dificultades que existen
y que yo mismo
me he encontrado en mi vida profesional
son: la complejidad
de los fenómenos sociales
respecto a los que la ciencia
les cuesta en especial estudiarlos.
Hay también problemas y discusiones
de cuál es el método adecuado
en la investigación científica
y cuáles son los temas relevantes.
Discusiones en los que los científicos
a veces parecen un loco con un martillo
que cree que todo problema es un clavo.
O son como el viejo chiste del borracho
que busca las llaves debajo del farol
donde hay luz
y no donde realmente se le cayeron.
Otro desafío que encontramos
es la mala calidad de los datos
en materia de seguridad,
que, imagínense, es como realizar
un diagnóstico médico
con un termómetro que está roto.
Esto, además, se ha agravado
por el secretismo de los gobiernos,
la falta de disponibilidad de los datos
en materia de virtual.
Por ejemplo, en Argentina por ocho años
no se tuvieron estadísticas en el delito
y de hecho yo fui uno de
los directores del equipo
que con mucho esfuerzo
pudieron recuperar esas estadísticas.
Por otro lado, también nos encontramos
con problemas de comunicación
y mutuo entendimiento entre las ciencias,
con los políticos, con los jueces,
los policías o la misma sociedad,
y que solemos esperar grandes verdades,
soluciones blanco sobre negro.
Y, por ejemplo, no siempre se nos
explica bien qué es la incertidumbre,
las probabilidades, las limitaciones
intrínsecas del campo científico.
Además, no todo es ciencia.
Hay conocimientos y criterios de decisión,
que la exceden, por ejemplo,
conocimientos profesionales
de índole práctico, aspectos éticos,
incluso cuestiones de consenso político
o distributivas,
las cuales son también muy importantes.
Por otro lado, de parte del Gobierno,
también nos encontramos
inercias institucionales, intereses,
o incluso corrupción,
que generan su negativa a brindar
información y a su vez rechazo
a tener que limitar sus decisiones
en base a criterios
que no sean sus propios intereses.
Entonces,
tenemos que pensar cómo dejar de usar
recetas que no sirven,
si es que queremos disminuir
el delito en América Latina
y mejorar las políticas de seguridad.
Creo que en la sociedad y la opinión
pública deberíamos aprender
que hay políticas del delito
que funcionan y otras que no.
Y que hay algunas pocas que quizás tienen
un respaldo de la evidencia científica.
Y otras que quizás solo se hacen
por inercia o por interés.
Además, el campo científico en América
Latina mostró una mayor preocupación
que actualmente es poca
en problemas de inseguridad,
teniendo en cuenta las propias
limitaciones que tienen
y tratando de salvar
las vallas comunicacionales
con el resto de la sociedad.
Por otro lado, tenemos que también
cambiar los incentivos
de los actores gubernamentales
de forma tal de que no se dejen
llevar por sus peores impulsos.
En forma similar a cómo
Ulises fue atado a un mástil
para evitar ser atraído
por el canto de las sirenas,
debemos atar a los funcionarios,
pero con instituciones,
para así lograr mejores políticas
contra el delito.
Algunas de ellas pueden ser:
la transparencia y accesibilidad
de la información sobre seguridad,
sin ellas es imposible
el conocimiento y la investigación,
la creación de sistemas obligatorios
de planeación para que exijan que
la toma de decisiones esté basada
no solo en formalidades o intereses,
sino en evidencia científica
sobre qué es efectivo y qué no.
Con forma similar que se exige una vacuna
si ha sido testada previamente
antes de usarla.
Además, todo eso debe estar acompañado
por un sistema obligatorio de evaluación
para saber finalmente
si sirvió lo realizado o no,
y que haya rendición de cuentas, además,
y aprender lecciones a futuro.
Entonces y así,
resultaría posible disminuir el delito.
Pero para ello, nosotros mismos,
como sociedad, debemos preguntarnos
sobre la eficacia de las políticas
y exigírselo al gobierno.
Y para lograrlo, la evidencia científica
fundamental, en forma similar,
que exigimos dicha evidencia
con la pandemia.
Con dicho fin, necesitamos cambios en los
sistemas científicos y gubernamentales
de América Latina, institucionalizar
la transparencia de datos
e institucionalizar también
sistemas de planeación
y de evaluación
sobre política de seguridad.